[Música]
[Aplausos]
diga com quem andas e eu te direi quem
és
a gente poderia com muita tranquilidade
de mudar essa frase para o seguinte
medida em que comunidade que você teve
que eu vou te dizer quem você é
ao longo da vida a gente passa por
dezenas de comunidades e cada uma tem um
efeito na nossa maneira de ser e de
pensar
umas mais outras menos e eu queria
compartilhar com vocês três experiências
importantes de comunidade na minha vida
a primeira delas é onde eu me construiu
que a minha família onde nasci e cresci
na segunda delas é onde eu me discutir o
que a família que eu criei meus filhos
ea terceira delas é outra miss her
significa que é a universidade onde eu
tô família
liguei essa minha família meus irmãos
meus pares família algo intenso 24 horas
por dia em baixo do mesmo teto há muitos
anos e você compartilhando tudo sala
cozinha banheiro quarto privado pasta de
dente mesa televisão tudo e é nesse
turbilhão que a gente aprende as coisas
mais fantásticas da nossa vida a gente
aprende palavra simples como o amor
compaixão companheirismo a gente aprende
palavras um pouco mais difíceis como
hierarquia obediência disciplina
tolerância perdão e na família que a
gente ganha os sentimentos mais
profundos que a gente vai carregar pela
vida da mãe por exemplo a mãe ao ser
mais carente que existe na face da terra
e fica mais carente na medida em que a
gente cresce toma rumo não é a minha mãe
era extremamente carente e dependente
quando ela era mais galinha eu tinha que
ligar pra minha mãe todas as noites para
que ela executasse a minha voz e pudesse
dormir tranquilamente e de repente essa
mulher morre morre nos meus braços numa
noite num quarto do hospital
aquele corpinho ali frágil na gru que
gemia pele e osso e de repente ela dá o
último respiro e morre
agora e naquele momento eu falei mãe vai
agora ser descansa você está aliviada e
eu pensei agora estou aliviado também
porque a minha mãe me demandava muito
naquela hora eu sentia tudo menos alívio
gente devastado arrasado desconstruído
exposto frágil como assim ela dependia
de mim eu não dependia dela não é no
entanto essa mulher vai embora e leva um
pedaço da minha alma e meu coração
como é que é isso
e nessa história toda eu percebi o
seguinte quando eu ligava para minha mãe
todas as noites
não era o que precisava escutar minha
voz era eu que precisava escutar a voz
ano em que outra comunidade a gente
desenvolve sentimentos tão profundos tão
enraizado na nossa alma
eu não acho exagero falar que é na
família nessa pequena e primeira
comunidade que a gente forma essência do
nosso ser e acho também que não é
exagero falar que a gente molda ao mundo
através da família pois é nesse sei o
que nasce o cidadão que depois vai pra
fora e vai fazer o mundo
a família é tudo eu queria falar pra
vocês
tomasi da catarina a minha família eu
tive filhos mais velho assim tinha 40
anos quando fui ter filho ea experiência
de ver o filho e por que eu fui mais
velho porque eu queria fazer mestrado
doutorado e pós doutorado antes de ter
filho
no final das contas pós doutorado é algo
complexo elegante sofisticado e
certamente iria me ajudar a criar o meu
filho
a experiência de ver tomás na c&a
catarina únicas maravilhosas é uma
mistura de sentimentos abrir a barriga
da mãe
você tá ali aquele sangue começa a sair
do buraco de 60 se sente à vontade de
vomitar depois de desmaiar mas depois
que sai da barriga da mãe se esquece a
mãe e você não consegue tirar o olho
daquela coisa mais delicada a minha obra
prima minha coisa mais bonita
eu contei os dedinhos para ver se
estavam todos inteiros assim e é tanta
emoção que nessa hora dá vontade de
chorar na frente dos médicos a gente não
pode fazer isso nem desmaiavam metais
chorar
aí eu me recompus respirei fundo e olhei
pra aquele ser completamente frágil
dependente ignorante eu falei meu deus
eu vou ter que ficar com isso o resto da
vida agora e aí uma semana depois o
tomás mamoru trocou você começa com
aquele ritual de arrotar não é ser
feminina que começa e resolvi ter uma
conversa de pai para filho a primeira eu
falei pô mas você não sabe o que é um
pós doutorado mas eu vou te falar
após outro lado uma coisa elegante
chique complexa e difícil de certa pois
orgulhe se o seu pai é o pós doutor
poucos meninos nesse mundo tem esse
privilégio
aliás eu não vou te ensinar a falar
papai e mamãe eu vou te ensinar a falar
do autor
assim quando você precisar de alguma
coisa você me chama
aí eu tirei o thomaz aquino foi assim
aliás não é nada pessoal mas você é um
ser ignorante
eu tenho muitos anos de vida tem
pós-doutorado eu sei quase tudo e daqui
pra frente a nossa vida vai ser simples
e ignorante você você aprende e eu
ensino nessa hora eu tirei tomada daqui
ele já tinha votado né
eu fui olhar pra ver se ele tinha
entendido tudo que eu tinha falado ele
nessa hora ele vomitou a minha vida de
pai não começou bem
talvez um dos grandes aprendizados que
eu tive na idade mais madura foi
perceber que não é assim
isso não funciona não é ele aprende o
ensino
eu tenho que aprender eu tenho que
aprender o que ensinar e como ensinar
esses pensamentos eu penso que eu tenho
que botar meu filho no mundo maluco como
esse e isso influenciou todo o resto da
minha vida foi dominador
eu queria falar para vocês da u
a experiência onde eu me ressignificam
quase todos os dias e são os alunos
formandos aqui da ufmg eu sou
privilegiado
sou privilegiado porque o trabalho
naquilo que eu sempre quis
eu adoro essa universidade a minha casa
me sinto aqui como se eu tivesse no ar
toda segunda feira de manhã eu chego
sorrindo e feliz porque vou começar a
semana e quando eu comecei desde o
primeiro dia eu adoro da aula eu entrei
na sala 40 calouros tudo com cara de
assustado e é o mais nervoso ainda mas
eu falei esse cara eu tenho que me impor
aqui ó
senão esses meninos vão montar em cima
de mim e eu falei assim meninos vocês
não sabem o que é um pós doutorado
mas eu vou falar pra vocês é uma coisa
super elegante sofisticado e chique
orgulho em si porque nem todo mundo tem
um professor com doutorado
os meninos não vomitaram mas não quero o
título do professor mais babaca não
funciona mais gente isso não funciona
mais a 20 e 30 anos da minha época um
professor fez algo parecido e ali fiquei
com uma admiração profunda e um respeito
mas é verdade
merece respeito esses títulos todos né
mas hoje não é isso que conquista
almocei com um amigo meu um tempo atrás
professor na hora do almoço a gente fala
muito mal de alunos né
e aí conversa vai conversa vem ele não
estava num dia muito bom e de repente
ele começa a desabafar e não aguento
mais alunos
eles não se interessam por nada eles não
me respeitam eles escolheram o celular o
tempo todo eu não aguento mais esses
meninos não conseguem fazer a minha
própria e eu fui tentando validar tudo
que esse professor falava algumas coisas
sim outras não e nessa história pensei
no rochel 20 e 30 anos atrás também
estudante
o que seria do chelsea ele tivesse aqui
logicamente eu me achava melhor do que
qualquer estudante ali né
não não sou melhor é só um tapado o
cheiro de 20 30 anos atrás no meio
desses meninos de hoje seria um tapado
não sou mais conectado ligado global
sábado eu não tenho mais capacidade de
argumentação do que esses meninos de
hoje tem no entanto para aquele
professor o rochel tapado de 20 anos
atrás seria o aluno perfeito ideal
existe claramente aqui um problema eo
problema é o mundo mudou e com ele as
pessoas e os nossos alunos entrantes ea
gente não se deu conta totalmente disso
você pudesse representar o mundo de uma
forma gráfica e suas mudanças seria
alguma coisa assim
a gente nunca deixou de evoluir a gente
sempre evoluir tecnologicamente a gente
evolui no comportamento individual e de
grupo etc mas teve uma fase da nossa
história em que essas mudanças elas não
afetavam profundamente as coisas a gente
vivia numa fase que a gente tinha alguma
estabilidade alguma tranquilidade e mais
importante alguma previsibilidade em
algum momento da história várias coisas
convergem para um ponto e põe o mundo
fica maluco eu não dou conta mais de
explicar o mundo de uma maneira simples
do mundo agora é muito mais complexos
as mudanças são muito rápidas e
assustadoramente imprevisível olha isso
aqui a gente sai dos anos 80 fax carta
tem gente que tem saudade disso
realmente escuto isso com alguma
frequência
e aí a internet se populariza
e aí no espaço muito curto de tempo você
começa com email redes sociais
buscadores e tudo isso vai combinar
naquele equipamento para tudo o que ele
trouxe de bom e de mau para o nosso
mundo
o smartphone antigamente era isso era um
telefone no canto de uma casa uma pessoa
de escape falava com outro telefone no
canto de outra casa era um para um
hoje qualquer lugar do mundo eu sou
capaz de acessar centenas ou milhares de
pessoas que estão na minha rede social
ou usando a minha agenda eu consigo
marcar uma reunião com 1020 pessoas
o mundo mudou e as pessoas mudaram a
pílula se populariza gente sair foi uma
revolução a gente não costuma pensar
muito nisso né
divórcios começam a aumentar e se
popularizam tudo isso mexe uma coisa que
a gente
provavelmente tinha uma mais sagrada ea
mais fundamental que a família família
pai mãe filhos cachorro cachorro sumiu
um certo momento na família não é mais
isso congresso nacional ano passado
discutiu o estatuto da família qualquer
definição de família a família pode ser
pai filhos mãe filhos pai pai filhos mãe
filhos
meu deus há 20 30 anos atrás eu sabia o
que era um homem uma mulher e sabia qual
era o papel de cada um no mundo
felizmente hoje a gente ficou livre
dessas amarras desses padrões e hoje eu
tenho uma liberdade muito grande de
decidiu que é o ânimos a anima o que é o
ser feminino ser masculino
o resultado de tudo isso gente é isso a
gente sai desse modelo de família a
figura paterna central os filhos
sorrindo fingindo hierarquia e
obediência a mulher sorrindo phishing do
amor e subserviência hoje família é
muito mais que isso aqui ó que a
obediência por obediência não não tem
mais isso a deus pais déspotas e
autoritários
agora o pau quebra porque os jovens de
hoje eles exigem a conversa a discussão
a argumentação e tudo gerou um monstro o
monstro chamado adolescente
eu morro de medo dos meus filhos na
adolescência por isso esse é um tema que
eu penso muito não sei se você lidar com
adolescentes
os adolescentes antigos eu sabia da
minha época neste item os baby boomers
pós-guerra uma geração tranquilo paz e
amor estável
e aí vem a geração x que aquela que
começa a ter algum contato com a
tecnologia se apodera de parte dessa
tecnologia e vem a geração y a geração
inovadora que se apodera completamente
essas tecnologias e aí a gente vai
combinar na geração z é o nativo digital
e se ele nasce na tecnologia se apodera
completamente dela para tudo o que tem
de bom e de ruim
esse é o cara que fica
conectado o tempo todo
olha isso aqui pra quem vai ter filhos é
isso que vocês vão enfrentar muito em
breve e eu queria chamar a atenção para
um ponto enquanto o mundo evoluiu
evoluir muito e tem pedido coisas
diferentes enquanto as pessoas
especialmente os jovens evoluíram e
querem coisas diferentes nós da
universidade a gente não evoluiu quase
nada
vinte anos de universidade e eu tenho
acompanhado esses 20 anos uma sala de
aula de 1960 e 70 é a mesma sala de aula
que a gente tem hoje as metodologias não
são tão diferentes como que resolva esse
problema tem um descompasso tem um gap
essa não é uma situação simples não é
uma situação trial eu não sei a resposta
disse eu penso muito respeito disso e eu
queria compartilhar com vocês algumas
coisas que norteiam voltar pros meus
filhos eles são as minhas inspirações
aqui ó mundo eu quero deixar para os
meus filhos
vocês já escutaram isso essa pergunta é
ruim é ruim do ponto de vista do
educador porque eu queria um bando de
mimados acomodados que tenha a há a
crença de que eles merecem um mundo
perfeito pra eles não a pergunta é que
filho eu quero botar no mundo que
profissional que aluno formado eu quero
colocar no mundo para que eles mudem
mundo eu não sei o que esses meninos vão
ser
eu não sei se eles vão ser químico
jornalista engenheiro eu não sei
a única coisa que eu quero muito é que
eles sejam felizes mas como pai
professor eu sou muito ambicioso eu
quero formar a geração protagonista que
vai mudar o mundo eu não sei se eles vão
ser essa geração se eles vão mudar o
mundo
isso é uma decisão deles mas como pai
professor eu tenho que fazer tudo e dá
tudo pra que eles possam se essa geração
quanto mais eu penso nesse tema
mas chega à seguinte conclusão o que vai
fazer essa geração que vai mudar o mundo
não é conteúdo
daqui a 20 anos não é conteúdo que vai
diferenciar esses meninos
porque conteúdo eles estão em boas
escolas
eles estão em boas universidades e
conteúdo está garantido milhões de
meninos como esses vão ter conteúdo
se não é conteúdo que é é o conhecimento
tácito é comportamento é atitude
a inteligência emocional e isso é que
vai fazer a diferença quando eles
entrarem se tornarem cidadãos do mundo
aí se eu tivesse que pensar em três
coisas que eu gosto de trabalhar com
eles auto conhecimento criatividade e
capacidade de execução
daqui a 20 anos o mundo é imprevisível
não sei como ele vai tá eu tenho que me
conhecer bem para poder me reposicionar
no mundo daqui a 20 anos eu vou precisar
de muita criatividade para olhar o meu
entorno e pensar de maneira
completamente inovadora e eu preciso de
capacidade de execução para implementar
qualquer mudança no mundo como é o
trabalho isso com os meus filhos de
maneira gostosa lúdica bacana eu vou
para o meio do mato com ele seu caminho
trilhas montanhas eu escalo leonardo em
cachoeira gelada
a gente brinca com alguns bichos
rastejantes outros mais pelo dinho se
olha a cara de alegria da catarina foi
uma conquista para ela segurar esse
lagartos a gente desenha e pinta a gente
constrói a gente constrói jangada com
garrafa pet a gente constrói abajur e
vende a gente compõe música toca e se
apresenta não estamos gravando um cd com
esses meninos e o que é que eu faço com
esses caras da universidade quase tudo
que eu fiz com os meus filhos a gente se
diverte também mas dá pra fazer mais dá
para publicar livro dá pra publicar
livro de coisas que a gente normalmente
não têm aqui no nosso ambiente e mais do
que isso dá pra fazer os cursos em
algumas disciplinas diferentes onde eu
trabalho outras habilidades humanas
desses meninos
dá pra empurrar esses meninos para fora
da universidade
ali eles vão ganhar bagagem dá para
colocá los em competições competições
aqui no brasil e fora a gente o mais
importante é a geração que vai mudar o
mundo eu não vou formar
esses meninos sentado na cadeira
recebendo o conteúdo de um professor
falando lá na frente
a geração que vai mudar o mundo é a
geração que constrói as suas histórias e
eles constroem histórias fora dos muros
da universidade
o galeano falou os cientistas insistem
em dizer que a gente é feito de átomos
moléculas elétrons etc mas um passarinho
sempre vota e lembra a gente na verdade
a gente é feito de histórias muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]